we want to go now from there to
Barcelona about 62 miles north
it is Spain's second largest city and a
major destination for tourists from
around the world Debora patta is there
talking to survivors of the deadly
attack Debora good morning good morning
incredible Caesar at Las Ramblas where
hundreds of Barcelona residents have
turned off clapping and chanting I am
not afraid in open defiance of
Thursday's attack packed with tourists
from around the world Las Ramblas was
turned into a chaotic scene of carnage
on Thursday bodies were strewn along the
street as people ran panicked in all
directions Robyn
native New Yorker Alex Lucca is on
holiday in Spain with his family it was
a belated celebration for his younger
sister's birthday within seconds it was
panicking they arrived at Lester Don Gus
in a tour bus just as the terrorist van
began mowing down pedestrians upon
impact you just start seeing bodies and
you start seeing people sprinting and
you could tell like that was a
definition of fear his biggest concern
was for his sister Luca recorded this
video as they made their escape I just
told you everything I said I told her
you and I are one person now you do what
I do you listen to what I say and you
don't go anywhere without me Barcelona
resident Liam Searle was skateboarding
down the road when people began
screaming but running for their
he didn't stop to look but ran for
safety into a nearby theater when I was
inside the theater they were treating a
small girl outside and she was probably
from the ages of like I don't know 6 or
7 and she was screaming our eyes out
pain Searle says he cannot block out the
horrifying images that he saw yesterday
but people in Barcelona he says will not
be defined by fear and death during the
chaos of Thursday's attack many families
were separated from each other including
a seven-year-old Australian boy who is
still missing his mother was injured in
the attack and his family desperately
appealing for information on his
whereabouts Nora
alright Debora patta there in Barcelona
thank you